hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play outlast
ok so we just got out of the forest of
doom and I think I've been here before I
dropped in the same again so I don't
know exactly where I've been but I just
got a battery so I'm happy okay so we're
going into the female area of the
complex which I'm sure will be perfectly
normal and not psycho bonkers crazy ha
what not you what what whoa whoa okay
not your babies I I'm all over it man
I'm not your babies what the hell was
that what the hell those so messed up is
he still following me Huck why you gotta
be so close to me man wait oh you just
needed to use a bathroom oh okay how you
going to your flame Oh which up I'm
gonna poke you with my with my missing
clap don't move around alright
huh I'm just gonna manhandle you for a
little bit excuse me
oh I'm breaking the game but this is to
attach anything not to do hahaha oh
what's that oh what's that
what oh you're not so tough now you're
prisoners what oh yeah what yeah I my
face won't you get in that back I'm
gonna give you I'm gonna give you a
swirly just come here come here
imma get you in the toilet get in the
toy okay nevermind moving on from that
a-hole and going down here I was wasting
my battery the whole time I did it again
wait a minute haven't I been here before
oh no this is a different area okay
here's a different dead body are those
is that two batteries oh my god
oooh batteries wool is this Christmas oh
my goodness
okay come on go down or up down her up
let's go down because that's probably
where the nightmares are and I want to
be near to those uh uh what what did I
trigger what happened so something in
the darkness is there something awaiting
me in the darkness something hmm
I mean that musics pretty darn ominous
don't tell me there's nothing tell me
there's nothing don't tell me there's
nothing I know your tricks game I've
been playing you for a few hours
oh I did not see you before he's just
standing there like a weirdo
you're literally just standing there in
the corner oh my god that's like the
Blair Witch product okay at first or the
first paperclip provides a means of
obtaining services of foreign
specialists for specific assignments
within the technical services of the
department's of Army Navy and Air Force
project 63 is primarily a denial program
with utilization as a desirable feature
the aim of this program is to secure
employment the aim of this program is
secure employment in the United States
of certain preeminent German and
Austrian
specialist thus denying their services
to potential enemies okay that was
oh yeah the sound again now is strange
why was that a thing why did I need to
come down here
oh yeah cuz I wanted to see the
nightmares that's right well good for me
I'm not gonna sleep well tonight I
haven't been sleeping well the past two
nights huh huh Iver I almost walked
right into that can't climb up on the
railing maybe wha what the huh well fine
I'll go back down to the nightmares
again there must have been something
else down there that I could have used
like maybe I'll grab a plank of wood and
Bridget across maybe I'll just ask this
guy down here I'll ask this guy hey
normally whoa ow k wasn't supposed to do
that that guy did not want to be
friendly or maybe he wanted to be a
little too friendly late hey let me show
you this nice friend how are you doing
well I'm just the biggest city that ever
existed in the entire world I'm so
stupid
I never even bothered to try and jump
what kind of [ __ ] am I the biggest
douche nozzle kind ever I'm such a [ __ ]
that was so stupid Lia I cut a lot out
there you didn't see how long I was
wandering for and probably for the best
but judging by my battery gauge you can
probably guess how long I was wandering
around like an idiot so congratulations
you're smarter than markiplier good job
everyone gold stars all around except
for markiplier he's a dumbass well
thanks mr. priest I've been trying to
get to you no matter what and you just
keep going forward ah screw you and your
priestly ways how do I get oh there's a
walker blocking this one Oh No
alright now I'm gonna be lost again cuz
I can't figure it out
oh good this door needs a key mister
senior priest efface oh okay oh through
the blood well that's good what happened
here look like that got burnt down
is that right above the kitchen okay
okay yeah I know the battery's low I
know these things I can see I can read
okay
yah yah yah yah yah yah yah who's out
there who's out there oh you're not dead
are you you might be dead
I'll let's change out my battery real
quick you better still be dead when I
get my okay you're building this flies
around give me that battery
give me that battery taking it what's
down here pray for revelation if you say
so
looky you're gonna close the door
goodbye goodbye forever ah nope not
going in there ever ever ever ever ever
ah god damn it where'd you come from
what where'd you go oh you're still
there okay ah what am I looking at okay
quick what the hell's going on here
why the hell those guys in both
directions alright listen who's talked
to this guy here hey buddy you actually
seem kind of normal except for the dead
guy I'm gonna creepy crawl my way around
you don't see a thing
oh he's like the other creepy guy you
probably won't bother me until I go near
him probably probably that a battery
fuse for the laundry chute you didn't
see anything
ah oh isn't walking slowly what's up
with that he's just walking why is he
just walking is more disturbing than
running it's just enough my god damnit
where no come from no [ __ ] you it's
another guy ah yeah what are you gonna
do now get a batch down and waste some
time while I run away like a little baby
what the hell where they come from
oh my god wait is there something there
batteries Scott him yeah well now look
close it oh there's oh yeah okay block
it block it
yeah what now Oh can't see anything it's
dark in here
okay all right that should hold him in
fight the wall Rider
I've already seen the wall Rider um he's
not exactly a nice guy I don't think I'm
gonna invite him to my birthday party
dah just saying you know I'm just saying
you know that's my party I wanted to boy
what is that what is that oh that's so
cool that's a window never mind I
thought that was actually something god
I'm going through these fuses like
nobody's business
alright so oh wait a minute how am I
supposed to get out
Oh freaking frack what was the point
attack who was the point of that I need
to get back I haven't even seen the
laundry chute that I need to put the
fuses into so I have no idea one yeah
where'd they go oh they wonder what ah
ah Frick frack nobody better be standing
in front of me whenever they're yeah
okay okay so where's this laundry chute
that I need to put these in oh yeah
there was another way to go there was
this way over here wait what oh no I
this isn't it this is a hidey hole but
there was a leap of faith to be oh my
god oh yeah no no no no how are we I
jump right into him who are you son of a
[ __ ] oh you son of a bit closer that's
a door oh there was a door there I
wanted to close that okay what do I do
whatever there's enough use go go go go
go around okay
so I got three fuses but I don't know
what to do with them I don't even know
where I went from here to there cuz I
kind of got distracted by the monster
right in front of my face
okay oh this yeah put him in pull in put
him in put him in the back oh oh my god
stop it man Jesus where do I go what do
I do
where do I go what do I do
I'm going the wrong way aren't I I'm on
the wrong way
what is that what is that what what is
that what is that what was that it
stopped
was I having a stroke okay okay I got
these fuses in oh I see Wow
really I couldn't have forced that what
No
oh crap
I don't why I go down Oh am I mean what
do I do about that what what okay you
felt down there goes oh I didn't even
see him okay there might be a way down
the only way that I know to go down is
well down the stairs you know no you
know man leave the faith and all that
then I was too stupid to make before
maybe it fell all the way down into the
basement here I guess that's a distinct
possibility sir a new dead body down
here hey anyone seen a dead body hey
mister have you seen it I was hoping it
landed on your head and killed you but
okay dead body not down it was a good
idea it's good idea Martha bar you did a
good idea had a good idea good thought I
saw something it didn't work out but
that's okay you know that rights all
right you know you have good ones you
have bad ones you go about your day
where could it have fallen I was over
there to the right but I can't get over
there to the right because it's all
blocked up so how do I get over there
that is the question
okay whatever I don't have time to yeah
there we go okay so there's gotta be a
way to get down and apparently I can't
slide down the laundry chute like a
waterslide of some sort I mean I'm sure
there's enough blood so that it would be
a smooth ride but I guess that's just
not good okay wait what about over here
wasn't there another way no no this is
where the priest won damn you priest
just stop hiding these keys in crap and
give me the way to get to you I'm ready
and willing to who's that dripping blood
or water hopefully water I'm ready and
willing my body is so ready when you're
just teasing me well I mean what I'm
really you're still glowing here but I
mean okay what is my objective use the
upper floors to reach father Martin do I
have any notes don't drink the water so
much blood in the water I can smell it
like putting a penny in your mouth when
you're a kid the whispers are making
more sense I'm looking for static it's
like an itch like an itch wait a minute
isn't that what the crazy guys said so
I'm kind of going crazy now okay I don't
know how to get down other than the way
I went and it looked like the way I went
was knock oh wait a minute no wait wait
wait whoa whoa whoa whoa wasn't there
another way back into down into doobie I
might've been down into doobie maybe I
did grab the key I don't even know what
the kids ones go to did I grab the key
did I grab the key do I have a kid I do
not know if I have a key I wish I could
grow oh there you are is a laundry room
Eric oh yeah all right I knew it I knew
it
hey thanks buddy you're doing good work
there all right all right all right so I
got a key which means I know
I never know which ones are just gonna
not come after me or which ones actually
want my blood
so anyway katenka Changa got that one
that was an ordeal geez thanks for
nothing priest E okay so anyway oh look
another leap of faith ah ah
follow the blood well that's a good
enough objective as any anyway I'm all
out of time for this part so thank you
all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video bye bye
ha ha don't need to tell me twice
here naughty - ha ha ha gonna go get it
use it use it get it good [ __ ] you King